face to face is a documentary that I
made because I was feeling really
disconnected and isolated from the world
and i was using social media a lot to
connect with people and it just wasn't i
wasn't feeling fulfilled i didn't feel
any kind of human connection and i had
five thousand friends on facebook so I
had this idea and I posted a status
update and I said the first 50 people
who say yes I'm going to come to your
city I'm going to spend the day with you
get to know you see if we're really
friends and make a movie and within like
nine minutes I had my 50 people and I
raised all the money on Kickstarter we
had one of the most successful
Kickstarter foam campaigns and I set out
on the journey and was gone for four
months I drove almost 12,000 miles met
50 people and it was a really it was a
powerful journey because it wasn't just
that I had had surgery and that I felt
depressed I really questioned why i was
on this planet what i was doing here and
if i really wanted to be here I just
felt like I didn't understand the
purpose of my life and one of the 50
people that I met was only have two days
to live and that was so powerful for me
and so life-changing because here I was
a very healthy young person ready to
check out on my own and here was this
person fighting for their life and
wanting their life I just felt like such
a schmuck you know and it changed my
whole perspective on everything and all
the people that I met during the journey
I don't it must have been divine
intervention because it was whoever
randomly happened to be on facebook at
that moment that said yes of 5,000
people to have all these 50 people
somehow be interconnected and
intertwined how is that possible without
fate and destiny and so it was just it's
just a life-changing journey and their
life changing for all those that were
involved i think so you think that they
needed you just as much as as you need
them yeah i think we needed each other
you know i think that they were craving
human interaction as much as I was and
now even I mean the movies just come out
and people want me to come international
like they just want to come hang out and
like it's not just because it's a movie
it's you know people genuinely want to
be with people and to interact more so
it's it's kind of uncut I don't think
it's a movie it's more of a movement
that's what it's feeling like it's like
a real movement if you'll do a face to
face Europe or face to face Russia yes I
I've been approached to do a face to
face international which I'm thinking
about and I've also been approached to
make it into a series because I've got
500 hours of footage of amazing story so
I just need to figure out what the best
places for the artistic baby you know I
don't want it taken over I don't you
know I want it to stay organic to stay
real and raw so I'm just kind of taking
it day by day and seeing where the path
leads
you